[Applause]
so what's your name anyway
hey kid it's a big shot gangster he's
putting together crew you think
everything sounds like a bad idea if you
come with me you're getting this life
for good
waited a long time for a shot like this
I got a really good feeling about this
hey everybody it's Charlie so surprise
they dropped a new Star Wars Han Solo
trailer and it looks like Han Solo is
meeting Chewbacca for the first time
like he says hey what's your name and he
just growls at him if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the movie videos we're hitting
summer movie season so like we're just
getting started with all the big crazy
stuff this year I looked the way that
Chewbacca reacts to everything I don't
think they're gonna lean on him too much
for comedy in the film I just think
they're using him to take a little bit
of the piss out of Han Solo because it
has a giant chip on his shoulder
which is indicative of the character in
his early years before he met Chewbacca
he was always really roguish mistrustful
of authority figures but you Baca had a
huge role in shaping his personality as
you see it when we see him for the first
time during Episode four it seems like
based on the way they cut this trailer
in the last trailer and some of the
dialogue that this happens relatively
early in the film this train heist but
before he's joined the crew and he runs
into Chewbacca while this is happening
but also runs into in fost the leader of
the cloud rider gang there was a line of
dialogue in the last big trailer where
Emilia Clarke's character Kyra is asking
him why are you doing this and one of
the reasons is revenge they flashed
emphasis with the pirate gang like that
shot of him pulling his gun out of its
holster so they might just be competing
interest or maybe emphasis was hired by
someone else to hijack this train it
looks like it goes sideways and it blows
up Chewbacca and Han Solo barely escaped
with their lives and this would have
puts them at odds maybe n fost ness
becomes sort of like his Boba Fett in a
small way for this movie like Boba Fett
pursued han Solo
for a long long time before he finally
caught him so that might be what
emphasis does throughout the course of
this film but if it wasn't clear even
though she's wearing Mandalorian armor
this is a pirate gang they're called the
cloud riders it's not like they're a
bunch of bounty hunters hired by Darth
Vader to go hunt down people we finally
found out who jon favreau is playing
it's the small alien here we don't have
a name for this person yet but there
were a lot of people that were confused
about who this is it's a new character
that we've never seen before I don't
know if it's gonna speak with Jon
Favreau's voice or they're gonna
related or how big the part is it might
just wind up being a couple small scenes
but funny thing in real life Jon Favreau
is directing the live-action Lion King
remake Simba is being played by Donald
Glover or Lando Calrissian so it's just
like this Disney's situation where they
own all these companies so you see
actors and directors reuniting on all
kinds of different projects all over the
place within a couple years of each
other really glad we finally get a shot
of Warwick Davis's character we don't
know who he's playing or what his role
in the film is going to be but they're
sort of using him like they're John
Ratzenberger picks our good luck charm
like in every Pixar film John
Ratzenberger appears in some funny role
it's not always a really big one but
he's always there and he's become
something of a good luck charm for the
studio so work Davis is just one of
those people like he's part of the Star
Wars family but now especially with the
new films he's been in every single one
in a different role the other big part
of this is them focusing on the savate
game it could be the you know capital
t-h-e the savate game where he wins the
money Falken or it could just be another
one probably one of my favorite
Chewbacca reaction shots where like he
looks at the cards and just turns away
like you saying oh [ __ ]
this just sucks the thing I think
they're trying to invoke with this is
that he has a totally crap hand there's
no way that he's going to win and
they're sort of calling back to that
moment in Episode four where Han Solo
talks about luck hokey religions and
ancient weapons are no match for a good
blaster to side
[Music]
I call it luck in my experience there's
no such thing as luck you get a couple
more shots of them being pursued through
this giant space maelstrom by the Star
Destroyer in these tie fighters which is
probably from what the actual heist is
for they're putting the crew together
Woody Harrelson's Tobias Beckett
character gives in that speech like you
come with me this is what you're doing
for the rest of your life like this is
it kid the run that they're making might
actually be the famous Kessel run
because we know that Kessel is gonna be
a location during the film there are a
bunch of locations that we just learned
about starting with the recruitment
center Imperial Academy training
facility battlefield the Penn's is
something called the Penn the den which
is probably this bar where they're
playing this game of soo bahk the
spaceport the TIE fighter Factory the
camp site the bridge the impound the
chase which is probably just this chase
through the Maelstrom here the refinery
canteen the coast the tavern the Droid
Arena the backroom the Operations Center
the landing platform in the spice mines
so obviously you know legendary Kessel
run probably gonna be a big part of the
film but in the way that these big
movies sort of demarcate themselves with
big action set pieces in different acts
you can think about this one as being
the big one of the film for those of you
asking about the other Wookiee that
Chewbacca is head bumping I think it's
pretty clear that that's probably his
wife I don't know if they're gonna make
any jokes or make any references to the
holiday special like when everybody
references that they talk about lumpy
but I think that this is his wife mala
so they might be invoking her we've
never actually seen her in any of the
other films before we've been a Kashyyyk
before during the prequels but we
haven't spent a whole lot of time with
the Wookiees beyond Chewbacca in some of
these moments there hasn't been a whole
lot of Lando in these trailers and even
though this is Han Solo's backstory
we'll learn more about Chewbacca's
backstory I don't know how much of
Lando's backstory we'll learn because we
have got some of him during rebels and I
think the idea is that this is all
happening before the events of Star Wars
rebels so if you watch that TV show and
you see how he sort of helps the
rebellion out as it's forming this is
all happening after his life as a
smuggler because I think what Han Solo
meets him he's sort of at the peak
visibility then there's the implication
that Han Solo cheated in that game of
soo bahk but all the Canon has said
about him during the rebel series is
that after he lost the Falcon
he went to Lothal and became an
entrepreneur which was sort of the path
to him becoming the administrator of
Cloud City this is a pleasant surprise
what can I do for you this isn't a
social call Lando
it's business we need your help to
smuggle something awful at all past the
Imperial blockade I'd be taking an awful
big risk what do you want what have you
gotten imperial shield generators
military-grade so let me know in the
comments because we're getting so much
Chewbacca in this film and some of his
backstory do you think that they
actually referenced the holiday special
whether it be some sort of funny
momentary reference or it actually
becomes a big plot point like they
actually canonized some of those
characters because technically it's not
canon even though it occupies a very
special place in Star Wars fandom but
what'll happen is is the Walking Dead
finale is tonight I might have some time
to post some more Marvel before that
happens
leave all your video requests in the
comments below click here for that last
big Han Solo trailer and click here for
a brand new infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight